Доброго дня шановні колеги звісно
європейська Солідарність буде
підтримувати ухвалення цього
законопроекту з місця якого співпадає з
тим який ми подали зареєстрували ще рік
тому але не тільки тому справа в тому що
саме цей закон врешті поставить крапку в
Довгому шляху який Ми пройшли для того
щоб Відірватися від російського
победобессе я нагадаю що на початку
2000-х років ініціатива відзначати разом
з Європою День пам'яті і і перемоги над
нацизмом саме 8 травня була громадською
ініціативою вперше в 2014 році цю
ініціативу почали відзначати вже на
державному рівні державній інституції
такі як міністерство культури і
український суд національної пам'яті в
березні 2015 року указ про те що 8
травня буде днем пам'яті і днем
примирення підписав Президент Порошенко
в квітні 2015 року тут парламент ухвалив
пакет декомунізаційних законів які
затвердилися тоді Було це важко Тоді 50
ще навіть в 2018 році
59% українців вважали для себе надзвичай
дуже важливим День Перемоги як як свято
але ми працювали ми працювали для того
щоб позбавлятися від впливу Росії
зокрема в цьому ключовому для неї дні в
результаті Минулого року вже 2022 року
таких людей для яких було важливим День
Перемоги було лише 15%. цього року їх ще
трошки менше 13%. Тобто ми нарешті
дозріли до цього щоб Відірватися від
Росії в одному з ключових для неї питань
питання яке є ключовим для її ідеології
расизму питання победобестя тому якісь
що нарешті ми це зробимо краще пізно ніж
ніколи і Я впевнений що цей крок це крок
до нашої Перемоги Я впевнений що в нас в
календарі чи вакантним залишається наш
день перемоги і впевнений що відмовить
Победы - Це те що зробить нашу перемогу
і неминучою і набагато більш швидшою
Слава Україні